Carlos signed as a candidate for Red Bull in 2025.
Oh, my.
Recently, there have been some reports that Carlos
signed as a top candidate for Red Bull
next year since as we know,
he currently doesn't have a seat for the 2025 season
as Lewis Hamilton is set to replace him at Ferrari.
But recently, Christian Horner has been saying some things about Carlos
Der Redbull corner
saying that he wouldn't grill out the possibility of Carlos signing to
turning to Red Bull. And after the Australian Grand Prix,
he said this,
that sometimes you've got to look outside the pool as well.
And at the Australian Grand Prix,
you had a very fast unemployed driver win.
He basically
also said that he wants to have the best driver pairing possible.
And sometimes that does mean
looking outside of the current pool of Red Bull drivers.
Are we going to see Carlos Sainz alongside Max Verstappen next year?
Will Carlos Sainz return to Red Bull?
I genuinely wonder what's going to happen.
Early season is truly here.
I hope you guys like this video.
Thank you so much for watching.
And as always, stay tuned for more F1 content and updates.